wasn't that the turn for our polling
station
uh why no young man uh see we
we know a uh shorter route to your uh
to our democratic polling station you
know how us democrats like a shortcut
like government spending to prop up the
economy nothing more we love than those
uh
federal programs you two are democrats
aren't you
what of course we are
you see the color of our skin don't you
how could we not
blindly vote democratic i mean that
would be ridiculous whatever
all i know is my polling place closed in
15 minutes why that would be terrible
awful i mean how are you going to elect
tax and spend politicians if you can't
vote
it's hard enough to vote with all those
voter id laws
republicans
gosh darn republicans i know i'm just
like girl
douglas right you know if there were any
republicans here
i'd be pissed i'd be royally pissed me
too
in fact i would take their hard-fought
principles and not shh
of it right off their keisters we
seem to be driving in circles uh don't
worry
we're almost there
look it appears we've hit somebody we
should get out and help him
oh oh my leg oh
i am pissed i'm royally pissed
now although it was only this one man's
fault i will be using all of your
tax dollars to get healthy thanks to the
affordable healthcare act i know it
doesn't seem fair but
that's supposedly the law of the land
out there that's what i've heard you
don't
look that hurt why are you wearing those
same leather jackets
and those dad jeans dispersed
black republican mother
you